Hier
[Musik]
Ich vermisse meine Freunde. Ich habe das
Gefühl, dass meine Eltern sehr gut darin sind
, mich mit ihnen zusammenzubringen. Ich spiele
mindestens zweimal pro Woche mit einem meiner Freunde auf Minecraft.
Normalerweise
denke ich, dass wir nach einem Jahr eine
Routine haben  wie Elliot sagte,
wie ein Teil des Stoffs, wie unser
Haus Tag für Tag läuft, ähm, und wir sind jetzt alle ein
Teil davon,
also weißt du, ich habe das Gefühl, dass einige Eltern sagen
, dass sie ihr Kind unbedingt wieder ins Krankenhaus bringen wollen
Klassenzimmer
[Musik]
Demonstrationen
wir sehen zunehmende Depressionen
Angstzustände
soziale Isolation Kinder fallen
schulisch und sozial immer weiter zurück Ich bin heute hier
, um für meine Kinder zu kämpfen Töchter
sitzen ein Jahr zu
Hause vor dem Bildschirm er kann nicht  Holen Sie sich die
Lektion,
er sieht seine Freunde nicht, er bekommt
nicht die Hilfe, die er braucht, wenn er eine
Frage hat,
also funktioniert es hier in Amerika einfach nicht,
und an High Schools können sie sich
viel weniger
ängstlich fühlen, und die Mitarbeiter identifizieren wirklich
Dinge, die sie  brauche t  o tun
und und bereiten Sie sich
auf den Start für Studenten am 19. April vor.
Ich meine, es war
einfach schwer.
Wir hatten ein hartes Jahr für einige
Studenten in unserer Gemeinde
Um mit der Schule beschäftigt zu bleiben, kann ich es kaum erwarten, einige Schüler aufzunehmen
und ihnen tatsächlich in die Augen zu sehen und
Hallo und
Ausländer zu
sagen  ist eine der besten Studien,
die im
Laufe der Jahre zu Impfstoffen durchgeführt wurden, und
allein in dieser Pfizer-Studie wurden 44.000 Patienten untersucht, das ist eine
unglaubliche Menge an Wissen und Daten.
Wie Sie wissen, ist dies ungefähr so sicher, wie Sie diese
Hilfe erhalten können [Musi
],
dass sie
innerhalb von nur einem Jahr einen Impfstoff entwickeln konnten
, der sich als sicher und
wirksam erwiesen hat, das ist super,
super beeindruckend, und es ist
auch verrückt, über die Reichweite nachzudenken,
die haben kann, wie
wir hineingehen und kommen  Ein paar Schüsse können
die Kinder betreffen, mit denen wir zur Schule gehen, für
jeden im Land und auf der
ganzen Welt,
Washington, also ist es
Ihnen fremd